hello everyone welcome to today's
webinar
titled investigating sensitivity
improvements on the ultivo tq
using 3d printed atmospheric pressure
ion focusing devices
i'm andrea klein of labruts and i'll be
your moderator today's educational web
seminar is sponsored by agilent
before we begin i'd like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
so we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you
as you would like during the
presentation to do this you just type
them into the ask a question box and
click on send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
and if you have any trouble either
seeing or hearing the presentation you
can also click on this
ask a question box and then indicate
that
in that space as well i'll now present
today's speakers
dr patrick bethune product manager of
triple quadrupole lcms at agilent
technologies
and dr brett marsh post-doctoral
researcher at purdue university
for a more complete biography on both of
our speakers you can visit the
biography tab at the top of your screen
dr batune i'll now turn it over to you
to begin your presentation
hi everyone and thanks for joining this
talk i'm here with brett m
marsh a postdoctoral research scientist
at purdue university
as part of professor r graham cook's
aston labs
we're here today to share some of the
scientific investigations
regarding 3d printed atmospheric
pressure ion focusing devices
and the agilent instrumentation used for
these measurements
this research was carried out on an
ultivo triple quadruple lcms
under a collaboration and research grant
to investigate
next generation ion focusing devices the
most attractive aspect of ultivo
is its small size compared to other
instruments such as our legacy 6460.
as we've developed eltivo we did not
want to compromise on analytical
performance
and aim to retain the performance of the
6460 instrument
the nice thing about ultivo is that for
tightly packed
routine laboratories they are able to
fit three times the amount of
instrumentation
when compared to our legacy instruments
when we first started this collaboration
i was an r d chemist
in the lcms quadrupole r d group at the
time
and worked with these two scientists to
get the instrument set up
and running of course their studies are
unconventional
in that they have no use for the
electrospray ion source that we provide
and have opted to use their own homemade
nano spray
source i pointed out that we can run a
simple
electrostatic nano spray setup by
grounding their emitter with an
alligator clip onto the chassis
so i was really happy to play a very
tiny miniscule part
for this type of research
before i transfer over to brett i'd like
to point out what makes the eltivo
really unique
and how we were able to maintain high
amount of performance
in such a small package oftentimes
people equate
small to less sensitive or incapable
so in order to preserve instrument
sensitivity
many traditional components had to be
reconsidered and redesigned to operate
in a small form factor
a traditional octopus ion guide used in
our other instruments is way too large
so the cyclone ion guide a twisted and
tapered hexa dodeca pole was invented
the twist essentially allows us to
achieve iron beam compression
and focusing without bending any of the
rods
standard two centimeter rf only brew
baker pre-filters
are too large so one millimeter
dc only virtual pre and post filters
were developed instead
these defeat french field effects in a
similar manner
but with a drastically smaller size
the quadrupoles had to be shrunk which
is a manufacturing challenge on its own
so we've optimized frequency and r0
to achieve the broadest sensitivity and
transmission possible
for this size and lastly
the vortex collision cell was invented
based on the cyclone iron guy's design
as it is also twisted and tapered it
maximizes
iron recollection after fragmentation
while maintaining the ion energetics
of these 6460s for the same collision
energies
so many hardware innovations were
included on this platform
that we were recognized in 2018 as award
winners by ibo
and scientists choice for the technology
alone
as the product manager of lcms triple
quadruple platforms now
there is always an interest in
miniaturization while maintaining
analytical performance
the ultivo was the first step in
miniaturization without compromising any
of that
we've only just begun in this space so
with that i'd like to transfer over to
brett
to share with you the exciting science
regarding 3d printed
atmospheric pressure iron focusing
devices
thank you for the introduction patrick
so as patrick said i'm going to be
talking about
using these 3d printed ion focusing
devices
with the ultivo so before i get into
that work
i want to start by acknowledging some of
the people that helped in this work
of course karan iyer who patrick talked
about was here at the start of the
project where we got the altivo
um the key bromlon is currently working
primarily in this area
along with rob schrader and by a very
talented undergraduate
he's actually starting grad school at uw
madison in the fall
grace capec has been involved in these
as well
from agilent's side we've had a lot of
help from patrick
and shane ticky and i just want to say
it's kind of a testimonial to this
university relations program
we've always gotten a lot of assistance
in these projects and
you know i personally like that they're
funding this sort of
blue skies research you know this is not
something that i think is for everybody
but we're moving towards applications
and a lot of that is due to agilent
support
so why do we care about atmospheric
pressure ions
since the early 90s electro spray
techniques have become
the de facto method of ionization
in almost every lab but not only electro
spray
paper spray nano spray desi dart
and other techniques have all produced
ions and air
and all require an understanding of ion
motion at
elevated pressures
so to understand the complications that
come from high pressures
i think it's best to think about the
electrospray process
here we have a droplet formed from an
electrospray emitter
which is held at some high potential
typically a few kilovolts
where the droplets formed it of course
experiences
gravitational forces it also experiences
electrical forces from the potential on
the electrospray emitter
in vacuum this is all that it feels uh
unless they're
ion optics for instance but at
atmospheric pressure
it's fighting against this wall of
molecules that exist around us
macroscopically we can describe this
with a drag force
but microscopically we know that this is
due to
collisions of these ions with the
background gas
so the motion of an ion at these
elevated pressures
is described by the mean free path
lambda
which depends upon the collision radius
of the ion with the background gas
for the average sort of small molecule
ion
that most people are looking at these
ions will undergo collisions about 10 to
the 10 times per second
of course the droplet can undergo
collisions at an even higher rate due to
its increased
diameter this constant energy transfer
between ions and background gas has
severe consequences
for particles in the open air
for example this is a calculation of the
translational energy
of a three micron droplet produced at
roughly 30 times thermal velocity
and vacuum in blue and an air in orange
in vacuum the droplet of course travels
along its path
uninfeated there's no energy loss
however in air the droplet quickly loses
energy
and by a microsecond it's become
thermalized
this means that the droplet in vacuum
will move
10 microns in less than a millisecond
while the droplet in air is virtually
stationary
whenever we add in an electric field to
this
we now have to start thinking about the
ions mobility
so at high pressure the mobility is the
main descriptor of ion motion
while in vacuum the ions energy and m
over z are the main descriptors
the mobility determines the speed a
particle can travel in an electric field
at a given pressure so here we have the
drift velocity v d is equal to k the
mobility
times e which is the electric potential
on the left you can see a typical ion
mobility
diagram we have in this case
a few of these tetra alkyl ammonium ions
which just consists of different alkyl
length chains around the nitrogen center
of course we know that this technique is
commonly used
at high pressures and in some cases you
can get very good resolution
and molecular information
for our purposes though we have to think
about how mobility
influences ion motion here
is an example of a three micron diameter
non-evaporating droplet with about a
hundred thousand
charges which is eighty percent of its
rayleigh limit
on the right we have a diagram showing
uh
z and x position of this ion as it moves
from
a two kilovolt nanospray emitter to an
aperture held at 1.5 kilovolt
as you can see the blue which
corresponds to the vacuum
and the orange lines display wildly
different trajectories
and it's even more stark looking at
their energy on the left side
as you can see and vacuum this droplet
with a hundred thousand charges
reaches over a million eevee of
translational energy
while in air it reaches about three ev
obviously we know that droplets aren't
always getting up to
a million eb in air so this really shows
that
these droplets are really subject to
huge forces
if we look at a number of droplet
trajectories
we can see that those droplets which are
in air show a strong focusing effect
compared to droplets which are in vacuum
this is even more highly demonstrated
by this comparison of a complicated
focusing device
simulated using semions sds
module here the electrodes
range and potential from 500 volts to 3
kv
the ions are traveling through to a
grounded plate at the exit
at ambient pressure the ion packet is
predicted to make it all the way through
the device
even though it undergoes some focusing
and defocusing
all the ions make it through for the
most part
in vacuum none of the ions make it
through the device with most of them
hitting the walls of the third and
fourth electrode
this is due to the enhanced speed of
ions
in vacuum these ions are traveling so
fast
that they can't adjust to the changing
electric field and continue on an
essentially straight line
in air the ions are traveling so slow
that these shallow potentials are easily
enough to steer the ions
one thing that i should mention is that
in all of our studies of ions at
atmospheric pressure
we've only ever applied dc potentials to
the electrodes
at these pressures rf frequencies have
very little effect on ion motion
so given these interesting traits of
ions at ambient pressure
there are two questions that we've been
focused on and
are now working with agilent to
understand
the first is how does mobility play into
ion transmission and focusing
the second is can these effects be
exploited to improve
instrument performance so before i get
to some of our data and experiments
i first want to talk about the
instrumentation that we use
the first piece of instrumentation is
the ion ccd detector
as the name suggests this is just a
charge sensitive
ccd device which can detect ions at
ambient pressure this thing has units of
digital numbers
uh dn so that's equal to 100 charges for
1dn
that's pretty much the detection limit
is 100 charges
it has a vertical strip of pixels as we
have oriented it
which we can scan using a micrometer
across an ion cloud to generate a 2d
ion distribution the images below here
of the nano spray plume
and the focusing of that plume through a
15 millimeter aperture
are kind of typical pictures of what we
see
whenever we make a two-dimensional image
i will also be showing several images
which are one-dimensional cuts
through these sort of images to get the
profile of a peak
but just to get you acquainted with this
we have horizontal position on the
bottom
vertical position on the y-axis
and we have a color bar which tells us
about the intensity
the other piece of instrumentation which
patrick has talked about
is our ultivo mass spectrometer
so as he said we've modified this for
use with external
sources and power supplies
as you can see in the picture we've
taken some of the junk off the top of it
since patrick has been there but it's
largely the same we're still running
without the normal source installed
what i personally like about this
instrument
is that it only requires nitrogen which
in our case we actually have hooked up
to a nitrogen generator
so there's essentially no consumables
and it's very simple to work with
to clean the source for you know even
using the software it's all very
straightforward
there's excellent documentation
you know i could give this uh thing to
my undergrad and have her do
whatever maintenance was needed no
problem just using
the documentation
so now that i've talked a little bit
about the instrumentation
i'll talk about some of our results
so the first set of experiments i want
to talk about concern the so-called
conical section
electrodes this piece of work began in
our lab in 2012
with this image on the top which shows
an ellipsoidal shaped electrode for ion
focusing
here this electrode was manufactured
using traditional subtractive techniques
and you can see that an electrospray
emitter is inserted orthogonally to the
ion
trajectory given by these red lines
the ions move through the device in
focus as they move towards the exit
so this study did reveal atmospheric
pressure ion focusing effects but we
wanted to take it a step further
so we looked at an ellipsoidal a conical
and a cylindrical electrode all made
using 3d printing
much like this previous example we put
several holes on the side so
we could vary the electrospray emitter
position
uh a lower number so for example on the
right you see the cylinder five
millimeter
corresponds to the nano spray emitter
being closer to the exit
and a larger number means that the
emitter is further back
from the exit you can see that
as we move the emitter further back from
the exit
the ion intensity detected by the ion
ccd
gets lower but the peak gets narrower
if we compare the cone the cylinder and
the ellipse electrodes
we can see that the cone gives us both
the narrowest peak
and the highest intensity five
millimeters from the exit
the cylinder is the second highest and
the ellipse
seems to have the worst performance
so one thing that our group is
interested in is soft landing
or ambient soft landing experiments so
being able to make ion beams
and control their current is really
important to us
and what we can see is that a
cone-shaped electrode
given by the red triangles seems to in
all cases
have a very nice focus and a relatively
high intensity
for the full width half max
however most people would probably be
more interested in
the applications to mass spec that we've
observed with these
electrodes so this is again
from the 2012 paper with an
ellipsoidally shaped electrode
in panel a you can see the effect of
focusing a tune mixture
with this ellipsoidal electrode
as you can see the main peaks are
caffeine the smurfa peptide
and these ultramark series of compounds
without focusing which is panel b
you can see that the mirfa peptide and
several of these smaller peaks around
caffeine
are actually suppressed relative to the
ultra mark
compounds so as i said
at atmospheric pressure we're interested
in mobility as opposed to mass to charge
so this implied that there is some sort
of mobility dependent effect
at play
we've begun to investigate this further
although i should say we started this a
couple of weeks before
we shut down due to covid so these
results are
somewhat incomplete but i think that
they do
highlight something interesting
here we've made a series of essentially
calibration
curves with a solution of three paas
with an internal standard which is the
hexel taa
all that we're doing is getting the ion
intensity
relative to the internal standard with
and without focusing
again all of these are in the same batch
they're all sprayed at the same time
and we're just looking at the changes in
the intensity
so one thing that's immediately apparent
is as we go from propyl paa
to heptal taa the slope of the
with focusing line so in other words the
sensitivity whenever we use the
electrode
seems to decrease as we get to the
higher mass
ion
looking at the ratio of these two slopes
where
slope one is with focusing and slope two
is without
we can see that there's some sort of
dependence upon the slope ratio
to the reduced mobility of the ions
in this case we have a ba corresponding
to benzoylamine
dba divinsol mean and tribenzolamine
along with the taa ions
so like i said this is still an
incomplete data set
we don't really understand everything we
have yet we need to do more experiments
but i think it kind of points to an
interesting application
for example you could imagine that
you're looking at a biological sample
which has a lot of lipid background but
you're interested in small molecules
maybe you could use one of these
electrodes to help remove some of that
lipid background
since those ions actually seem to be
somewhat decreased in intensity with
focusing
the final part of my talk will concern
the so-called
complex devices this is kind of a
catch-all for a number of different
3d printed devices our lab is made
what i think is interesting about these
is they allow for
complete ion manipulation outside the
mass spectrometer
we can really control what's going in
without having to do
any sort of vacuum steps anything really
complicated
just these simple 3d printed devices
so this device is from 2015
uh it's a simple four electrode 3d
printed device
uh you can see in panels b and c that as
the ions move through the device
they become focused and they do
follow this curvature pretty well
we can as shown in the bottom two panels
add in a vapor in this case it's a
phosphonate vapor
along with whatever ions we spray in
this case it's two separate amines
and we can form adducts between the
phosphate and the amines
we can kind of do an online detection of
these volatile species
this work led us to develop a 3d printed
ambient ion mobility spectrometer
out of 3d printed plastic
on the left you can see the completed
device
the middle columns shows the conductive
plastic electrodes that we use
and the right shows just the
non-conductive housing
this device uses no gases we're just
using
ambient air to do our separation there's
no flow
we only use dc power supplies it's just
a dc
gradient uh detected with a faraday cup
you can see this picture of me holding
the device it's about
10 centimeters long or so very short
the only metal are the screws that you
see and two grids inside the device for
pulsing
this is the same ion mobiligram i showed
earlier
but i just want to point out again the
resolving powers with this
device they're actually very impressive
the peak on the end is around 70
resolving power
so very similar to a commercial
instrument
we've taken this a step further and
while we're not quite getting into
the territory of the slims devices that
you saw in the talk before mine
we are generating some curved devices
which can have quite long path lengths
this device was part of an exploratory
study
to see if we could make an ims that's
compact
enough to couple to a miniature mass
spectrometer
as you can see from the experimental
data on the right
the drift times are quite long but the
resolution is still pretty good
the final piece of work in this area and
for my talk
concerns space charge compensation by
counter ion introduction
so this is something that's been known
in the field for a while
it's been especially used in particle
accelerators
but to my knowledge it has not been used
on such low energy ions
so briefly we're taking this curved
device which i showed a few slides back
electrode potentials from 3kv to 500
volts
there's also a rendering of it on the
left which shows
in red the conductive electrodes and in
green non-conductive electrodes
now we've added not only an electrospray
shown in red
but also a space to put in a negative
apci needle ions generated by the apci
are in blue and you can see that even
though they're negative
in this very positive field
most of the ions are predicted to make
it through
if we look at the ion packet with just
the spray on
you get the black trace here the fullest
half max is something on the order of
eight millimeters it's very flat
very wide whenever we add in these apci
ions you get the red trace
you can see that now the full width half
max is something like two and a half
millimeters
and the intensity is roughly doubled
so this is an indication of increased
focusing
i should mention that in blue you can
see
the effect of just turning on the apci
with no spray
and it gives you just the baseline so
we're not generating some weird ions
with the apci
with the apci off this is what the 2d
image looks like
again it's what you would expect very
broad very flat
with a pci on this peak becomes somewhat
asymmetric
and is shifted slightly towards the apci
needle
now i should say that we think that this
is actual ion ion interactions
because we've used a flat piece of metal
in place of the apci needle
and at the same potential we don't see
any of this focusing effect
so it seems like ion generation is key
to getting this focusing
to think about why this works i think
it's helpful
to look at this in a very uh sophomore
physics way
here we have two particles p1 and p2
they're the same polarity and there's
some force between them
which is dependent on one over the
distance squared
in this case i'll call this force f12
so the particle 1 experiences only force
f12 whenever we add in an ion
of opposite polarity we now have two
forces on p1
f12 and the attractive force f13
so we put this all together the net
force is now
f12 minus f13
this means that we're actually
decreasing the force felt on p1
from p2 by adding in this charged
ion and that is why this peak goes from
this broad eight millimeter
thing to you know about two and a half
millimeters or so
we're actually reducing the space charge
in the packet
uh there are obvious applications where
you could say
multiplex nanospray emitters and use
this technique to bring the beams
together to get very high currents
however you could also use this for mass
spectrometry
and our findings in doing that are very
interesting
on the left we have the sltaa with the
apci off
in black and 8pc on and red
and you can see that whenever we turn on
the apci
the intensity is decreased by about 20
percent or so
however whenever we go to a higher mass
ion like the octal taa
shown on the right turning on the apci
actually increases the intensity of that
peak
this is again a complete contrast to
what we saw with the
ellipsoidal and conical electrodes
so we still don't understand this effect
really
but it is highly reproducible
we're somewhat hopeful that we can find
a way to exploit this
to do some interesting applications
again though we don't really understand
the effect yet
we're doing some simulations now with
higher level
physics software to try to understand it
but it's
interesting finding nonetheless
especially because you would expect
lighter ions to be more affected by
space charge
so in summary ions at high pressure
display
wildly different behaviors and ions in a
vacuum environment
our lab has done a number of different
methods of ion manipulation and
atmospheric pressure
we really only ever use dc potentials
the instrumentation is much simpler than
a traditional in vacuum experiment
of course mobility effects can influence
ion transmission
and it seems like the focusing devices
can really play a part in increasing
those effects
maybe we could even possibly use them
for some application
we've shown that space charge can be
managed in these
low energy atmospheric pressure ions
which opens the door to brighter ion
sources in the future
but i should say that we don't really
understand a lot of these phenomena
still
there are a lot of questions especially
about the role that droplets play
while i started talking out about
droplets i
quickly moved on to talking about ions
because a droplet is a highly dynamic
environment
we need to be able to understand what
effect evaporation and ion formation
plays on the focusing and ion
transmission effects that we observe in
these devices
so with that i'd be happy to take your
questions in the live q a session
thanks
thank you both for those great
presentations we're now going to start
the q a portion of the webinar if you
have a question you'd like to ask please
do so now
just click on that ask a question box
that's located on the far
left of your screen i'm going to go
ahead and get started i'll let
the two of you dr batoon and dr marsh
decide who is answering
the first one i have is why did you use
3d printing to fabricate the devices
used in your experiments
yeah so that's a question that we get
quite a bit about this work
um the simple answer is that 3d printing
is really cheap
and in the case of the ion mobility
spectrometer
it's very lightweight that spectrometer
probably weighs about 100 grams
so for a field use case for a device
like that which is more applied it's
really good to have that lightweight but
it's really cheap and you can also make
geometries which are kind of unusual to
get by
normal machining so
you know it's really nice for us too
because we can just go in
dream up something and then an hour or
so we have it in our hand
so we like it for all of those reasons
okay
and then there's another question
related to that
what is this 3d printed material made
out of
are they doped with some kind of
conductive metal
so the plastics that we use here are
in almost all cases pla based
which is probably one of the most common
3d printing materials
in the case of the conductive electrodes
we
have a special carbon doped plastic
which you can buy
anywhere we get it off of amazon we've
also tried plastics which are carbon
nanotube dope
those work fine but they're just a
little bit harder to actually print with
um but in either case though you know we
find that these things
are not nearly as conductive as say an
actual metal
but you know the resistance across one
of these is
probably less than a mega ohm typically
for pretty much any of these devices so
still pretty conductive
okay i'm going to stay on this theme for
just a minute so putting on the spot
again
will the 3d printed part withstand heat
yes that's something we haven't explored
too much
obviously the plastic itself has some
temperature that's printed at
where it does melt and in the case of
the pla
you know we're talking around you know
maybe
mid 200 c range you could probably get
it too before it starts getting really
bad
but we also use petg
plastic which we print with at about 270
or so
and that seems to work fine up to that
range
so there is some heat stability
uh one thing with this ambient ims that
we've thought about
is including a desolvation region like
you would have a typical drift tube ims
but obviously heating this plastic as i
said we can go
reasonably high but probably not high
enough to efficiently desolvate
everything
so there are some drawbacks using the
plastic for sure okay
um switching gears now a little bit this
might be for dr patoon
um you mentioned some bias in ion
transmission
is this mz dependent mass dependent or
collision cross-section dependent
um tough question
in regards to the mass spectrometer
itself we're tuned
to to transmit across the m over z range
so a lot of these
observations are primarily due to the
um ion focusing devices but do you have
any more commentary regarding vm
i guess the you'd call it mass
discrimination
yeah so this is something we don't
really understand yet
as i showed we have you know six or
seven points which
look pretty good um but
the compounds that we picked their mass
and their uh mobility or our collision
cross section are
pretty much in lockstep with each other
so we haven't really done the
experiments to figure this out yet
and in fact we're actually getting back
to the lab this week so
that's one of the first things that uh
sakeb will be doing
i think though that it's almost
certainly a collision cross-section
effect
obviously at atmospheric pressure a lot
of these
mass to charge things are kind of
blanketed by the mobility effects
but i can't say for sure but i'm
extremely confident that it's a mobility
cross-section effect
okay excellent um not sure who this one
should go to
can you comment more on the negative
apci
source used to reduce space charge
what counter ion is used and can reagent
gases be
added to study ion-ion interactions as
well
okay yeah i think that one's for me so
we just used a needle held at
some potential i think in this case it
was at about
5 kb or so to generate a corona
discharge in the open air
so we weren't really selecting for any
certain ions it's just whatever negative
ions are produced by the discharge
and that's also why we use the taa ions
because they're pretty non-reactive so
i'm sure if we use something that was
more reactive we probably would have
seen
these reactive species generated by the
discharge
interacting more i think that to make
this
really useful you do have to take a gas
or some conditions to get rid of these
reactive oxygen and nitrogen species
so yeah i can definitely see an approach
where we
carefully select the gas and look for a
certain interaction
or reaction depending on the sort of
work we're doing
okay great next one is
stacked ring rf ion funnels are in
common use today
can you comment on the differences
between the two technologies
okay i'll take a stab at this okay yeah
sure
sorry brett yeah um in our in one of our
instruments the 6495c
we have an iron final device however
it's in partial vacuum and it is
evacuated at a
a lower pressure mode these devices are
completely atmospheric pressure
and i'm sure brett has a lot more to say
about that
yeah well i mean patrick's pretty much
right i mean if you look at this
ims device that has been developed in
the lab
it is just a set of rings some gradient
on it
but at atmospheric pressure we get
focusing without the need for rf
uh frequencies to be added unlike the
ion funnel
now obviously the focusing that we get
is
pretty good but you still have to go
through the atmospheric pressure inlet
of the mass spec
so no matter what you do i think you're
going to get quite a bit of ion loss
in that ims device and
as patrick said you know we are
operating at completely atmospheric
pressure
no pumping or anything um but this
certainly would not replace an ion
funnel
you know an ion funnel will take
everything that gets into the mass spec
and channel very efficiently
whereas we're entirely outside of the
mass spec
okay um there's two questions that seem
somewhat related i'll ask them together
and you can
decide if they can be answered at once
or not with the material being used in
the 3d printing
do they not present interference or
contamination
in the analysis and then relatedly
someone asked about any background from
leaching from the from the plastic being
used
yeah so i think that these are yeah
very related the short answer is
we don't see any evidence in our mass
spectra that
there's a background from the plastic
itself
i will say that if you run one of these
devices
for a while you can start to see peaks
from things you've previously put into
it
so there is something building up on the
surface but
i think that whatever is in these
plastics
you know whether tg or pla is pretty
stable
it doesn't seem to be extracted
certainly you know these things have
some
volatile chemicals i would assume
that can leech off of them over time but
we don't see any evidence of that
okay excellent um next i was surprised
to see the
increase in the positive ion response
when adding the negative ions from the
apci
have you investigated if it's from a
reduction in space charging
yeah so i you know again i can only say
what experiments we've done that we've
done this apci experiment
we've also done experiment where we put
the same voltage
on a flat piece of metal so there's no
corona discharge and we do not see this
focusing effect
so i i'm in complete agreement that this
is due to a reduction in space
charge due to the interaction of the
positive and negative ions
and this is something that's been known
um
for actually quite a while irving
langmuir actually
proposed this idea you know way back
so this is something that's known
to my knowledge it's not been done at
these high pressures with this low of
energy ions
so that's what makes this kind of unique
and it's really kind of exciting
okay great next i noticed the
ion introduction was carried out using a
nano spray emitter
how do you expect this to perform with
higher flow ion sources like esi
so generally i would say at you know
first glance i would expect there to be
pretty similar performance with higher
flow rate sources but this does bring up
you know the last point on my last slide
which is that we don't understand what
role droplets versus bare ions play
so with these uh higher flow you know
electrospray sources
you'll be getting larger droplets the
droplets will live longer than the
smaller droplets produced by nano spray
so we're still actually we have some
data looking into this but it's not very
conclusive
i'm looking at how different sized
emitters which give you different size
droplets uh influence focusing or ion
transport in the air
this is still ongoing though so i don't
want to speculate too much but
i would say that you will see focusing
effects whether they're of the same
magnitude or not
remains to be seen okay
and we're going to go ahead and wrap up
with one last question we're back to the
the 3d printing
topic do you have any commentary on the
size of the 3d printed devices
such as what happens as the device size
is either increased or decreased
so this is something we haven't really
messed around with too much
actually i can say that we did a series
of experiments where we
focused an ion beam through just single
apertures with different sized openings
as you would expect as the opening
decreases in size you get a tighter
focus of your ion beam
and to a certain point you actually get
increased
intensity of your ion beam as well
although it drops off
pretty quick once you go to smaller and
smaller apertures
as for these uh complex devices
you know this ims that we've built my
co-worker rob actually printed a version
of it that was half
sized in every dimension and we saw
very similar peak widths to the longer
ones that we've made
so that was kind of an interesting
result
i would expect that you could modify the
focusing
by changing the size of these devices
but something we
are still i guess you know haven't
really looked at yet
okay great well that's all we have today
so before we go i want to thank our
presenters one last time
for all of their work and they're
answering the questions and also thank
the audience for joining us today
and for submitting those questions for
that period
anything that we didn't have time for
today for the q
a and anything that gets submitted
during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speakers using
the contact information that you
provided
at the time of your registration the
webcast can be viewed on demand through
june of 2021 and until next time hope
you have a great day